thank you for coming here I'm so
grateful to be here thanks for inviting
me yeah I'm sorry you had an uber driver
that left you with a bumpy ride but
hopefully your stomach will settle my
stomach yeah good well it's a pleasure
to talk to you I've been wanting to talk
to you for a while
ironically I just had a phone call today
with my friend Jonathan Fields I know he
was on you were on his show and yeah I
adore him so had to say hello so I'm
excited because one of my favorite
obsessions is the stories we tell
ourselves about ourselves and how these
stories become powerful predictors of
future behavior yes and really can
define our lives and really set us on a
trajectory to live reactively and not as
intentionally or as mindfully as we
should and this is the sweet spot of
your research and this incredible new
book that is going crazy right now and
this TED talk that just went up a week
ago that already has you said yeah I
know it has over a million views and you
said there's a snippet that has 19
million years right there's an excerpt
of it and in one week the TED talk has
had two million views and the excerpt
has had 19 million views
but beyond the matrix the incredible
notes and emails from people are just
indescribable in the way they're
connecting with me I just feel so
encouraged and you know doing any of
these kind of things is a huge
investment yeah when you feel that
effect meaning it's what I would imagine
that you had to know I mean after right
you you published this article that was
the foundation of what would become this
book and what was in it was in the
Harvard Business Journal and that went
off like wildfire so that was sort of
proof of concept like okay people are
really responding to this so you knew
there was an interest in an audience and
and really more than that like a need
like everybody can relate to this issue
because it's something I think we all
struggle with on the
background yes both from my personal
experience and then from our research I
started to become aware of how so often
we experience things in society society
tells us to think positive or to be
happy or we get these messages and I
started to become aware firstly of how
sometimes the messages that we get are
unhelpful and then also to your point
earlier of how our thoughts emotions and
the stories that we tell ourselves can
start driving behaviors in ways that are
not connected with who we want to be in
the world and so I very much see this at
work I see this in parenting in our
personal lives and so I felt like I
wanted to write a book that really
started to convey both the ideas of
emotional rigidity which is when we
reactive on autopilot but also what are
the key components of emotional agility
where we are able to be intentional and
effective so before we even parse the
differences between agility and rigidity
maybe we should just define what we talk
what we're talking about when we're
talking about the emotional landscape so
my work really traverses emotions so
both the physical sensations and the
physiological sensations and also the
feelings so when we then construct
something that says I am sad because of
something the feeling the thought that
we might have soft arts and the story so
my work traverses this whole idea that
our inner world our thoughts our
emotions and our stories often drive
every aspect of how we love how we live
how we parents and how we lead and yet
so much of the writing that exists on
success is effectively writing that's
either about set goals and achieve them
or about the landscape of what success
looks like but there's very little that
focuses I think in an evidence-based way
and not to say that there isn't any but
in an evidence-based and research-based
way about what it takes internally
mm-hmm in the way we deal with our
thoughts emotions and our stories right
and and I think that begins
with really understanding that as these
emotions well up inside of us as they do
that they are part and parcel of what it
means to be human they're entirely
natural and the starting point is really
to discern the fact that you have a
choice when they arise as to how you
behave that you don't need to
necessarily self-identify with them to
the extent that they become that
predictor of behavior that leads you
astray absolutely yes so the first point
that you make which is that they're
naturally occurring experiences in us as
human beings is one of the first things
that I explore in both my TED talk and
the book which is that as a society what
a storage happen is that these naturally
occurring experiences that really are
incredibly important signals to
ourselves in terms of how we're doing
what's working for us in our lives
what's missing in our lives what started
happening is that emotions either feel
dirty that they've seen as being
disruptive feminine irrational illogical
or what happens is we receive this
narrative from society that says just
that there are good emotions and bad
emotions the good emotions are the joy
and the happiness and you should chase
happiness and the bad emotions are anger
grief sadness and so one of the most
critical aspects I think of my work is
starting to really challenge this idea
that they're good or bad emotions right
you really put out that our emotions
have evolved in us as a human species to
help us to respond and survive and when
we start getting into the space where we
either block or suppress or push aside
emotions we actually stop ourselves from
being our most effective successful
beings yeah this idea that there's a
duality is a socially projected emotion
yeah that perpetuates that vicious cycle
of you know unhealth I guess because if
you feel if you feel sad and then you
know like well that's a bad emotion then
you're going to then feel shame or guilt
for having that and you're just digging
that
even deeper and deeper yeah that's
that's exactly so it's this fascinating
thing where you know we have in
psychology we sometimes talk about type
1 and type 2 and type 1 is where you
start saying I feel sad and type 2 is
when you start having an emotion or
judgement about the emotion so you say
I'm sad that I'm sad I shouldn't be sad
I push it aside and in some of my work I
for example did a survey of 70,000
people and I found that a third of us
which is a remarkable number of third of
us treat our normal emotions emotions
like sadness or anger or even grief as
being bad and so we push them aside or
if we don't do it ourselves we often do
to people we love our children we jump
to solution and I think a critical
aspect of well-being is moving beyond
the struggle with our emotions into the
other space which is this is how I'm
feeling what do I need to do about this
context right to detach from the self
judgment that usually is accompanying
that yeah the the radical acceptance of
all of our emotions our our grief our
sadness our anger is a hallmark and in a
cornerstone of resilience and a
cornerstone of effective relationships
that's not to say that because we feel
angry we have a right to be angry and we
should act on our anger or because we
feel wronged we have been wronged but
rather what's at the core of my work is
this idea that our emotions contain
signposts to things that we care about
him they're these flashing lights you
know if I feel guilty as a parent it
doesn't mean that I should be guilty but
it does mean that there's a value often
that sits beneath that emotion that I
value presence and connectedness with my
children and then I'm not feeling enough
of it I'm not experiencing enough of it
so instead of judging the emotion if we
can rather be open-hearted and accepting
and compassionate of it we can start
moving into the space
we are able to discern values that
underneath it right I like the idea that
the emotion really sheds light on the
extent to which you're invested in that
value so that guilt reaction really just
reaffirms to you that that impulse to be
a good parent is sir is valuable to you
right and that's almost that's an
affirming way to perceive what you would
ordinarily you know feel lousy about
that's exactly and then and then we
start being able to make tweaks or
changes or shifts that bring us towards
those values because the way that I
think of values as values up to often
seen as these abstract ideas these know
these things that are you know on walls
in offices and mission statements in
businesses where values are packaged in
with it and so values can often seem
these very abstract ideas but I see
values as being qualities of action so
what I mean by that is every day every
day we have opportunities to either
bring ourselves towards our values if
you value health for instance you get to
make a choice that's either towards that
value depending on what you choose to
put in your mouth or away from that
value so we have these choices every day
and their qualities of action and having
the sense of what our values are that
gets informed by our emotions is hugely
protective of social contagion of you
know going down a path where you then go
how did I get yeah I didn't want to be
here how am I in this career and they
also allow us to shape our lives in
really meaningful ways mm-hmm and by
social contagion you mean that impulse
to compare ourselves to our peers or
what do you mean so this social
contagion there's this fascinating
research on social contagion and the
idea behind it is that we catch
behaviors and we catch emotions from
other people without even realizing it
so for instance we've all had that
experience where we get in an elevator
and someone's on their phone and we
without even thinking about a takeout
offer and we on our phone as well so if
we extend that if you for instance are
on an airplane
and you trying to lose weight for
example and your seatmate buys candy
even if you do not know that person what
the research shows is that your chance
of buying candy increases by 70 percent
70 percent so now extend this out what
we know is that large-scale
epidemiological studies show that if
people even with in that we don't even
know two or three degrees of separation
from us
get divorced or put on weight it
significantly creep increases our
chances of getting divorced or putting
on weight so you're like oh my goodness
of what is actually going on yeah
but we've all experienced that we got
for dinner and someone orders dessert
and so we order dessert so what starts
to happen is in so many ways without
realizing that we start wanting things
that other people want we start
comparing we start normalizing behaviors
and we see this at work everyone's
stressed we get stressed we said at home
how do you protect against that how do
you stay the course of what is important
to you and there's just this wonderful
wonderful work that shows that what is
called values affirmation so even
spending 10 minutes thinking about who's
the parent that I want to be who is the
leader that I want to be starts to bring
those values front of mind and actually
protects us from the social contagion
right so excuse me a couple observations
on that the first thing is is that so
much of your I mean this this idea of
values is really at the foundation of
everything because it creates this
cascading effect on behaviors down the
line but it requires maintaining you are
like a sense of clarity about what those
values are and keeping them front of
mind right as a driving force so I would
I would presume that requires some
practice and some effort to always be
like okay well what are my values and
what am i doing and how to how do my
actions align or or not align with what
I'm doing presently or what I plan to do
and then secondarily how do you
distinguish values from goals so um so
the first thing that I would say is I
think that you know values are
foundational here but
in order to even start understanding our
values we need to be able to be in a
space with ourselves with our emotions
with our being that is not in struggle
hmm where where we are able to be
accepting and where we are able to be
compassionate towards our experience
because it's out of that or that we we
discern we discern our values the
difference that I the just difference
that I make between values and goals is
that goals have an endpoint you know you
might say you know I want to run this
amount and that is that is a goal and
it's something that's actually
achievable but a value is actually
different it's a it's a life direction
so you never reach a stage for instance
where you say I am a good friend or I am
a good husband or I am you you know I am
a fair person rather a value is a
direction that you're trying to move
yourself in mm-hmm but you never reach a
point where you say you know I am X so
the right thing you would say is that
intimate relationships are a core value
or like sort of you know basically
fertilizing the intimacy of my
relationships is important to me yes and
as opposed to I want to run this far it
would be I want to live active you know
fitness oriented lifestyle right so in
applied to relationships for instance
you might say I'm being connected and
intimate and being one of the things
that I think about in my relationship
for instance is I want what I call a
clean relationship that's it
so that that for me is a value it
doesn't sound like value but what I mean
by clean relationship I mean a
relationship in which I am able to have
conversations that are important and
meaningful with my husband without there
being a whole lot of baggage about the
conversation so I feel like it's super
important for us that we can go to
difficult places and have meaningful
conversations whether it's about
religion or money or raising children
without there being these kind of no-go
zones because each of us are bringing
our stories so that's what that might
look like you know you might have a
value about a particular relationship
the way you might in act that value is
through particular goals so you might be
saying you know I'm gonna make sure that
a couple of times a week I have good
one-on-one time with this person so
that's what a goal might look like which
is very tangible but it's the value
that's right yeah one of the examples
you used is you know when your spouse
comes home or your partner like don't be
on your phone like put the phone down or
make sure that you're not that your
present and available for whatever it's
Jesus so this is this is exact same only
about of course values are these things
that were in our front of mind are very
very powerful we know that values help
us to enact and access greater levels of
willpower to create effective
sustainable changes in our lives and so
on but of course they're they require
some cognitive effort because you always
try to be you know what's the right
what's the value and so this is where
habits become so important and this is
where work on habits and how to create
habits become important so for instance
in the example that you give if your
value is a value about intimacy and
connection in your relationship but you
know that you have a particular habit
and that habit is to bring your
cellphone to the table every night
mm-hmm
and that stops you opportunity I can see
a look of recognition there so but if
that if that focus is something that's
important to you then one of the things
that are described in my book is how we
can make values aligned have a changes
and tweaks so say for instance you come
home from work and you always put your
keys in a particular drawer we know that
there's a very powerful way of changing
habits called piggy banking where you've
already got a habit that you engaging in
and so you now piggyback and you have it
on to that and so you put your keys in
the drawer and you put your cellphone
into the drawer as well right so it
makes the habit adoption a lot easier
correct and so you're not needing to
constantly think about oh ma you know
what is my what is my value here because
you're making have a changes that are
values aligned what about people I feel
like we skipped way ahead because we're
talking about values we just kind of
like scan but let's stay on this yeah I
want to go back into those
but on the subject of values what about
the people who don't have clarity about
what those values are you know the
people that are living reactively that
are living in that are sort of pray for
the looping of the of the impulses that
have that hooked that prevent them from
seeing clearly what it is that is
important to them
so I talked about this a bit in my book
and it's not you know it's not something
that's unusual I will often when I give
talks have people come to me afterwards
saying yeah either this is something
I've never thought about or I have had
parents who effectively have told me
what my values are and I've never really
been able to sort through what my own
values are or I'm so busy or I have been
so busy taking care of children or
earning a living or you know this is
nothing that I've just not had the
opportunity to give through the thoughts
what I'm trying to get through to the
through through the day what are some
ways that you can start guiding that
process um so there are a couple of
things that that I think are useful the
first is if listeners are interested
I've got a free quiz that's available
that many hundred thousand people have
taken on my website which is at Susan
David come forward slash learn and
that's got a whole list of different
values and what those look like but some
very simple questions things like um you
know when we when we finish at the end
of the day looking back on our dance
saying you know what today was
worthwhile for me not what gave me the
most fun what was most exciting what was
most worthwhile because stuff that's fun
and exciting isn't necessarily a value
you know you can go to clubs night after
night and have a lot of fun but it's not
necessarily a value so things like what
is worthwhile and the reason that
worthwhile is really important is
because there's often a level in
worthwhile of even discomfort or effort
that's gone into that thing but has been
important and I and I go through a
couple of questions that one can ask
oneself to start discerning this it's a
really you know important aspect another
thing that comes up is people say what
my values are in conflict you know right
what if this is a very common thing like
what if my values are in conflict what
if I value work and value my career but
I also value parent like being present
with my children for instance and one of
the things that I talk about is this
idea that you values you know values are
not these again dichotomous things that
you either have them or your values are
your values and so the the the where
that I describe this is if you imagine a
diamond and you imagine that some values
of front-and-center and sometimes in
your life it doesn't mean that the other
facets of the diamond on do they you
know we are complex in a good way
and capable and whole enough as human
beings that we are able to have many
values unfortunately because we are
mortal you know we can't be in two
places at once and so sometimes we have
to make difficult choices and and so I
explore about how these difficult
choices that we make for instance now
you know I'm in LA and my husband is at
home with my two sick children so you
make choices but but the choices instead
of being choices that are laden with
conflict and guilt become choices that
have far greater levels of clarity to
them the gray informed values led rather
than emotions driven mmm-hmm so for
example you being here you're not at
home your parent your your your husband
is at home with your children so rather
than browbeat yourself for not being
home and not being available as a parent
like what can you do while you're here
to serve that value what actionable yeah
can you do there's this beautiful
there's this beautiful concept in
psychology called social snacking or
psychological snacking and it's this
idea that you know it's not it's not
either/or I can be in LA right now
because it's important for me to be
doing the things that I'm doing and
that's consistent with other values of
mine which is about getting my message
out or connecting with people in
particular ways about this
it doesn't mean I don't care about my
children what it does mean is that I can
look at the context that I'm in and I
can make choices for instance that when
I talk to them later on tonight that I'm
actually a present with Everett or so so
and that's just an example but these
examples apply to our workplace that
applies to our health that applies to
our relationships that we can have
multiple values and they're not
necessarily in conflict some might be
more front and sent at particular times
so let's take a step back I want to talk
a little bit more in depth about the
stories we tell ourselves about
ourselves and the kind of emotional
rigidity that goes hand-in-hand with
that but I think in order to properly
contextualize it it's worth kind of
going back into your own personal
history because this is not just an
academic pursuit for you this this was
born out of your own challenges growing
up yeah yeah so I I yeah absolutely
these these ideas are not born out of
you know the hallowed halls over Harvard
I mean my life's work really started
when I was when I was young I as you can
hear by the accent I'm not American I
was born as a white South African in -
apartheid South Africa and so as you
grow up you have this growing sense of
horror at the society and what that
society is doing to its fellow human
being and really this is a society that
was founded fundamentally on denial
because it's denial that makes 50 years
of racist legislation possible while
people are convincing themselves that
they're doing nothing wrong and so there
was there was my context and from very
early on I started to you know ask
questions about you know what does it
take internally to thrive in a world
where there is both this
you tea and there's this fragility and
difficulty and then when I was 15 years
old my father who was 42 at the time was
diagnosed with terminal cancer and I
remember and I described in my TED talk
my mom coming to me and it was on a
Friday and my mom saying to me go and
say goodbye to your dad and me putting
my backpack down it feels like yesterday
you know me putting my backpack down and
walking this passage to where my father
the heart of a home Lay Dying and I said
goodbye to him and I went off to school
I didn't know that he was gonna die that
day
and he did and then the months after
that or even the days after that I went
back to school on the Monday and people
don't know how to have these
conversations they don't know how to
talk about grief or death so suddenly
you know all my school friends dropped
the word father from their vocabulary
with your father this weekend and
suddenly father's became non-existent
and I you know I'm growing up in this
world where there is this denial going
on around me and where we as a culture
even in today's culture even in a merit
beyond we value this idea of I'm okay
positivity you know what you feel
attracts everything else to you and so
when people ask me how is doing I would
say you know I'm okay I'm okay but in
truth in truth back home we were
struggling my father had not been able
to keep his small business going my
family was in incredible debt my mother
was raising three children
single-handedly and I started to spiral
you know I really was struggling to deal
with us and then you know again I just
remember this so clearly this eighth
grade English teacher handed up
notebooks to the class and she said it
to the class but I felt like she was
saying it to me and in fact I believe
she was saying it to me she handed out
these notebooks and she said right you
know tell the truth right like no one's
reading hmm and I started this
correspondence in this journal that I've
kept you this
and what I realized afterwards is it was
that it was not the I'm okay you know
positive thinking etc that actually
helped me to be resilience it was about
being able to go up close to my emotions
to understand them to be able to get
insight into them be compassionate with
them that ultimately was the process of
healing and resilience now don't get me
wrong I'm not empty happiness we can get
to it yeah it's it's the false bravado
that we we construct often that keeps us
in a stage of being disconnected with
our authentic emotional experience right
the phrase you uses the tyranny of
positivity which I love and I think it's
so accurate and what's amazing about
that story is is like the power of
somebody giving you permission to feel
in a climate of denial saying it's okay
and in fact this is where you need to go
and I support you and I have your back
and it's it's life-changing I would
write in this journal and you know
poetry and thoughts and I would hand it
in every day and this was as the secret
silent correspondence with misty chaste
beautiful and she would write back to me
and you know this went on for for many
months and you still keep it up now I
still keep it up not in the same yeah
you still have the original journals and
what was fascinating is that experience
then became the catalyst of my life's
work mm-hmm this idea of trying to
understand what it is that we often
experience in society because it is
often a tyranny there's there's this
idea that you know boys don't cry that
girls should smile that woman and people
who discriminated against should not be
angry and so what this does is it is it
these these are what we call in
psychology display rules the this kind
of implicit shaping of what it's okay or
not okay to feel you know the flip side
of that or the the really dark side of
that is it leads
people into situations where we know
that social policies for instance can
and do affect people's well-being and so
when we start having a narrative in
society that says oh it's all about the
fact that you aren't thinking positive
enough what it starts to do is it starts
to abrogate our societal responsibility
and recognizing that our choices can and
do impact on people's well-being yeah I
think that was one of the biggest
epiphanies that I took from your book
that I hadn't really thought about in
any kind of meaningful way before which
is how these things act on the micro and
on the macro and what and how the macro
is impacted by you know these these
denial patterns or these sort of
unhealthy social mores that we adopt as
a culture and how they play out not just
in your in your family or with yourself
but in your community and the planet at
large and when you really track that and
look at that you realize how powerful
all of this is it's it's so it's so
incredibly powerful internal pain comes
out mm-hmm and it it comes out in a lack
of compassion for the world it comes out
in a lack of compassion for life
it also comes out in for instance in our
parenting and being very
solution-focused with great wonderful
beautiful intentions with our children
but in ways that don't necessarily help
to develop their own emotional skills I
feel like that's changing now I mean we
all kind of intellectually know if
you're going through something difficult
like seek out help like ask for help go
to therapy confront these emotions but I
don't know how widely adopted it is or
how the extent to which it's practiced
with you know the less sort of
cataclysmic events that we experience
throughout our lives yeah yes that's and
I think that's right I think it's it's
you know one of the things that I
explore in the book very much as I try
to take the book both in the very
practical everyday you know here are
strategies
into the wider context of when when we
in grief you know what does that look
like and in many ways it's these
everydays of being able to shape our
intentions in our relationships and in
our in our health and in our well-being
that often those kind of ideas don't get
explored because there's they stall this
idea that there's again good and bad
emotions so we should just think
positive yeah let's and let's fast
forward a little bit to like the hooked
section in the book which is really
about these stories that we tell
ourselves about ourselves because I
think you know as as we kind of
discussed earlier you know we all do
this on some level whether it's feelings
of unworthiness or undeserving you know
our inability to find the right partner
for ourselves how we kind of view the
world the lens through which we perceive
everything is by definition this prism
that distorts reality yeah right so how
do we do like how does this happen and
then how do we develop the capacity to
see it objectively so that we can begin
to unpack it and move beyond it so yeah
so the definition II what I mean by
hooked in and being emotionally in agile
is when your thoughts your emotions and
your stories are driving your actions
rather than your values and your true
intentions so examples might be a
thought might be something like I'm not
good enough I want to apply for the job
I know I've got the skills but I'm not
going to get it so I don't apply or I
you know would love to go to the party
but I'm anxious of being rejected so I'm
gonna stay home or my husband's starting
in on the finances and I don't like it
so so when we hooked what's happening is
you know there's this beautiful
beautiful idea that I talked about in
the book which many of the you listeners
would have heard which is this Viktor
Frankl Viktor Frankl whose fires the
Nazi death camps speaks to this idea
that between the stimulus and response
there is a space and in that space is
our power to choose and it's in their
choice that comes our growth and freedom
when we hooked when our thoughts
emotions and our stories drive us
there's no space
between stimulus and response so we have
a thought we have an emotion or we have
a story about whether we good enough
valuable enough some of these stories
were written on our mental chalkboards
in grade 3 and they've become a prison
around ourselves and so what starts to
happen is there's no space between
stimulus and response we think we are we
feel and we just act so core aspects of
becoming unhooked and the core
underpinnings of emotional agility I
talked about it in four very practical
ways in the book and that's not to imply
that like it's step one step two step
three step four but really I talked
about these four movements if you like
the first is about being able to show up
to ourselves in ways that are curious
and compassionate and not in struggle
with ourselves so we're we actually able
to extend compassion to the fact that
you might have a story about your value
in life or you might have a story about
what relationship you deserve and that
stories probably come from somewhere you
know right there's something that
happens yes but what's interesting kind
of psychologically and neurologically
about that is there's always going to be
some inciting event there's some there's
some hook to which you're hanging you
know your evidence for why you tell this
story something happened you got fired
or you got rejected or something like
that but what makes you know it's like
that becomes the the sort of locus of
your attention even if it's rebutted or
refuted by a hundred other examples of
things that occurred in your life that
contradict that but for some reason we
make these decisions like no that's
that's the way it is hold on to that
yeah right so human beings are story
making machines and and actually we we
as human beings one of the things that
sets us apart is this making of stories
and the idea that creating stories helps
to keep a coherent narrative in our
lives that you know sense of it helps us
to say well you know the
that I'm hearing is the whirring from
the washing machine you know we can't we
would be on cognitive overload if we
were assessing every single stimulus in
our lives a new every single day so
human beings are story making machines
we have sixteen thousand spoken forts
every single day and many millions more
costs to our minds so what starts to
happen is we we we have all of these
thoughts emotions and we've got a
particular area of our brains called the
angular gyrus and the angular gyrus is
the crossroad of our memory taste visual
sensation and so what starts to happen
is we don't just have a thought like dr.
Spock you know I'm having a thought that
I'm being attacked or I am experiencing
this emotion our thoughts are
experienced in Technicolor we have
memories the last time this person spoke
to me how this felt when I was a child
and so as human beings we are wired to
have these visually real experiences
that are these stories woven in these
particular ways and this is actually a
key aspect of our survival as human
beings it enables us to say this person
who is about to attack me is not smiling
they're about to attack me because I've
got a memory of what happened previously
so stories are normal and I think one of
the things that I really stress in this
book is that it's not that this having
stories is bad
in fact sometimes the stories that we've
had in our childhood in our childhoods
have helped us to survive those
childhoods have been functional and
helpful for us but what starts to happen
is when you bring an old story into a
new situation in ways that don't serve
you so for instance if you have a story
that I don't deserve to be loved and you
then find someone who loves you and we
then acting in ways to push that person
away you've got a story that's not
serving you right right right
and so in the book I talk about these
ideas of you know being able to be
open to what that story taught you how
it might have actually helped you in the
past
and then where's to start getting some
perspective around that story noticing
the story for what it is a story one of
many stories but that doesn't need to
own you yeah I think that that the
process of becoming open to a more
objective perspective on your stories
would begin with understanding something
that that we're not really taught which
is that you can become an observer of
your thinking mind and you can call it
your higher consciousness the
terminology you know is up to you but
but we do have the ability to bifurcate
and understand that the looping of the
thinking mind is something outside of
who you are as an individual and that
you have a choice to whether you you
want to engage with that or like
disengage and become a dispassionate
observer of that and I think for me and
I mean I my kind of perspective you know
just for a little background on me as I
come from a long time sober and and have
learned through the process of recovery
in that community
you know a lot of tools for managing
this but I remember it being a
revelation like wait a minute like I
don't have to self-identify with this
like I can actually like I even just the
idea that I have a choice or that I have
agency over that was like oh my god a
completely mind-boggling inner and in
the book I talk about this this first
movement which is showing up at the
second movement is exactly this this
idea of stepping out being able to
notice your story and be compassionate
towards your story but not be your story
to be neutral to and so it's so you know
just really some some kind of
fascinating strategies around this and
we've all experienced this even in you
know subtle wares we've experienced that
the thing when you are outraged with
some customer service agent down the
telephone and you want to kind of vent
at the person and you you on fire
and then that little voice goes off
inside your mind that says Susan
if you rented this person that will
conveniently lose your file and not
solve your problem and so we've all had
that experience of being upset or angry
with someone and then had what is you
know a meta thought or metacognition and
you thought about our thought that helps
to create that sense of separation
between sturluson response and so you
know simple strategies that help us to
do this or for instance we often will
say things like I am sad I am angry and
what that does is it makes you all of
you 100 percent of you said whereas you
are more than said you you you've got
other feelings you've got other thoughts
you've got other stories you've got
other values and so simply just noticing
the thought for what it is which is what
you describe I'm noticing that I'm
feeling I'm noticing that I'm thinking
I'm noticing that this is my victim
story what that does is it starts to
create separation another way that we
can do this is to start labeling our
emotions accurately when you say
something like I am stressed again it's
all of you and it's this very diffuse
difficult to deserve emotion what does
that mean there's a world of difference
between I'm stressed because I was let
down by my team versus I'm in the wrong
career versus actually I'm kind of
grieving for lost time in you know so we
know there's this there's this
fascinating research in emotions called
emotion granularity which is this idea
that if you said yourself you know what
are two other emotion words to describe
my stress I'm disappointed I'm angry
what this does is starts to activate our
understanding of the causes of those
emotions and also starts to activate
what's called the readiness potential in
our brains where we start we're starting
to be able to set goals towards what I
need to do about the situation so there
many different strategies of perspective
taking and being able to move into that
observer space but it's incredibly
powerful yeah oh so much so I mean in in
in recovery it's sort of the
they call it the inventory like which is
sort of journaling right like which
helps you gain a little bit of clarity
over these emotional states the more you
kind of flush them out on paper but I
would also imagine that the journey
towards the process of trying to expand
that space that Viktor Frankl was young
about can be significantly enhanced
through meditation and mindfulness
practices because it really helps you
become that dispassionate observer yeah
yes so people will just you know people
will disagree with me on this I'm what I
talk about in this book is I think that
you know mindfulness is very very
powerful I don't think you necessarily
have to be mindful when you take up a
trash and my you know mindful every
second of the day but this creation of
space especially with emotions that that
trigger you or thoughts a trigger in
particular ways mindfulness is just so
powerful because what you're doing is
you are noticing the fort for what it
isn't in the thought noticing the
emotion these are data not directives
there's valuable information contained
in them but they're not directives and
it's that mindfulness is incredibly
powerful
yeah the data directives thing is huge
and I think you also say you know who's
in control here is that the is that the
thoughts or the thing better yeah right
he's in charge then and I think most
people are living reactively like
nobody's been sort of indoctrinated into
these ideas to understand like you don't
have to be reactive or responsive to
these stories in that kind of impulsive
compulsive way that most of us just sort
of live yeah and it's so it's such a
powerful thing I see the sea in so many
different spheres but but you know as an
example in children when we when we are
experiencing a child who is in pain for
instance a child who says something like
you know mommy I didn't get invited to
the birthday party and I'm so upset and
everyone else got invited so what we can
start seeing is that there's no space
between stimulus and response when their
child says Jack Tom invite me now I'm
not going to invite him and one of the
most powerful questions that we can
asking our children that helps to
develop their character and their
compass is who do you want to be in this
situation you know what is being a good
friend look like to you what that starts
to do is that starts to help the child
to understand that they you seeing them
firstly you helping them to label their
emotions but you also helping them to
empower themselves to make a choice
about the situation that's not
necessarily their first impulse right
and it's so powerful what about the
person who is a professional victim it's
everybody's fault you know
nothing ever works out for me you know
just doom and gloom with the you know
the it's raining on them wherever they
go no matter what and my experience with
this kind of personality type is you can
provide them with some you could say
here read this book or why don't you try
this or why don't you try that and that
person is generally disinterested in
that and more interested in searching
for evidence that reaffirms the victim
narrative well it was it's fascinating
one of the most remarkable studies that
I came across when I was researching
this book is and it just sounds
completely you know it odds with what
you would expect but it was research
showing that when people who've got a
story that is very much about a victim
and and you know low self-esteem and the
world is against me and and so it's very
very identified in this way so imagine
you've got someone who's experiencing
that story and that person is in a job
and that person gets promoted okay so
now what they're getting is they're
getting disconfirming evidence like
they're getting evidence saying actually
you you know you are or value you are
worth something so what is absolutely
stunning is that those people are more
likely to then leave the job because it
feels so discordant and so you know one
of the things that I think is just so
powerful is that I think that these
stories have functions and sometimes the
function is an excuse and sometimes the
function is self-protection because if
if I'm a victim then I don't need to
take responsibility and sometimes the
function is you know that that this
allows me to self-sabotage and I think
what's really important here is to
distinguish that kind of thing versus
someone who you know is truly
experiencing depression and you know so
because I think that's a really really
important distinction but I think what
starts to happen is is when you start to
explore what you often start to realize
is and what the person will start to
realize is that it may be a story and it
may have a function of protection but
that it's not serving right them and so
instead of becoming kind of judgy about
the story if we can help them to
identify what are values that that story
is taking them away from mm-hmm or what
are relationships or you know what are
what are other parts of them that are
not being enabled right right right
yeah I would I could see that you know
I'm just as you're describing that I'm
thinking you know somebody's walking
around their whole life with a certain
story like the idea that you're gonna
then say well do this and then suddenly
the story no longer applies like it's
complicated right this is a this is a
very difficult thing it is and I think
this is where you know this is where
being able to be more attuned and
nuanced to the for the person of the
emotion that they experiencing this is
where you know writing is incredibly
helpful because it starts to gain
insight this is where exploring you know
what are what are things that you
wanting to move in the direction of that
you're not you know this is not a one
conversation thing but I think that
these the what are ways that you can
start experimenting with different ways
of being that are more connected and it
take you to discomfort is just very
powerful
let's go back to this conversation about
the good and the bad emotions and our
sort of inability to just embrace that
the human condition is it requires all
of it you have this beautiful phrase in
your talk something about how you know
the beauty and the fragility of life go
hand-in-hand I can't yeah during it I'm
sure that this idea that we need to
embrace all of ourselves and that the
path towards healing and wholeness and
self-actualization requires us to you
know have have a meaningful embrace of
whatever life throws in our path yeah
yes it's it's it's this idea that life's
fragility laughs beauty is inseparable
from its fragility and you know I
explore in the book this idea you know I
think we've all had this it's like you
you walk around and you young and then
one day you realize that you're not
young you you sexy and then you realize
actually no one's even looking at you
anymore you you nag your children to
clean their room and one day there's
silence where their child once was you
healthy until you get a diagnosis that
brings you to your knees and really the
reality of life is that tough emotions
are part of our contract with life like
we we don't get to have a meaningful
career or as a family or leave the world
a better place without stress and
discomfort and yet we live in a culture
that pays lip service to like going
towards your you know going out of your
comfort zone but that at its core really
has this idea that there's good and bad
emotions and so you start looking at the
just frightening you know public health
crisis which is that depression is now
the leading cause of disability globally
right it's crazy that's just been
canceled insane yeah heart disease and
so I think that what starts to happen is
we start um almost creating a situation
where we aren't able to process
difficult emotions when we in a society
that tells us positive thinking is all
that matters or positive emotions all
that matter and so we we
actually don't we don't develop
skillsets around us and so I you know
have the core ideas behind emotional
agility is this idea that in order to
navigate the world as it is not as we
wish it to be we need to be able to
strengthen our capability with the full
range of this beautiful may see
difficult human experience right right
right
in a culture in which we're actively
encouraged to go out it you know go out
of our way to avoid all of these
unpleasant emotions and if you should
find yourself in the grips of them you
should be ashamed for yourself you know
and whether it's as simple as security
and safety young and luxury and comfort
and all that and and being you know
squarely within your comfort zone or
just you know the the sort of daily
emotions that we all experience on some
level along the spectrum of guilt shame
fear and and even just our language
which we often again it's with with good
intentions a friend of mine recently
died of breast cancer and she said to me
you know we were talking about this
tyranny of positivity and she said to me
it's so difficult because when you when
you have cancer and when that cancer is
terminal every person you come into
contact with tells you to just stay
positive just stay positive and what she
described is that it took her away from
actually being able to have the
authentic meaningful end-of-life
conversations that she needed to have
that even in her dying she was living
and she was able to and wanted to be
able to be able to have real
conversations with people that she loved
but it becomes very difficult when you
try to have those conversations and
people are like oh you being negative or
you or you know you're not gonna beat
this cancer it says more about the
discomfort of the person delivering that
because it is so uncomfortable for most
people to talk about death and the
things are scary so when they they may
be well intentioned saying stay positive
but probably most likely they're
uncomfortable with anything other than
that right so so it's their way of like
well I have to say something for the
it's a band-aid for the person who's
delivering that rather than actually
being fundamentally mmm hopeful so often
I'm not saying you know there might be
many people in the world who
experiencing illness with someone saying
stay positive is helpful mm-hmm but I
know that they're there many people that
I've spoken to who find that it feels
like okay now not only do I need to beat
my cancer but I've now got to deal with
these somehow bad fourths that I'm not
allowed to be having right and and hold
up this face of strength when you don't
feel like it and and feel badly if you
can't live up to that you know kind of
inside of that also is this idea that
you explore which is that the more we do
actively deny these emotional states the
more we empower them like below the
surface the more we try to pretend
they're not there the stronger they
become they're doing push-ups in the
dark well it's so fascinating so again I
just want to stress that I'm not empty
happiness or like empty being positive
what I'm auntie is what I meant here's a
narrative that constructs good and bad
around these things and then leads us
into stages of expectation that I should
be happy or that I can't be unhappy and
yet it's fascinating when you look at
when you look for instance at people who
have a very strong expectation that they
need to be happy and you track those
people over time those people become
less happy that there's this when you
when you hold this idea that happiness
is more important than meaning is more
important than purpose is one then what
it is is it sets up some kind of goal
that is fundamentally unattainable and
so people who's actively strive to be
happy become less happier over time what
it also does is it leads to greater
levels of in the book I talk about
different
ways of dealing with emotion that are
difficult and one way is bottling our
emotions will be pushed aside difficult
emotions the others brooding where we
dwell on and what's fascinating is when
you bottle emotions when you push aside
difficult emotions there's this there's
this effect that's that's an
amplification or rebound effect that
these emotions actually come back
stronger and more and people have
experiences if you you know again are on
a diet and you try not to think of
chocolate cake we know that you start
dreaming of chocolate cake when you ask
people to not think a particular thought
and you time them for a minute most
people will have that form that's been
banned 40 times within that minute so
this idea of trying to push aside
suppress move away from these difficult
thoughts and feelings it just doesn't
work right allow yourself to feel them
as part and parcel of being human but
also understand that thoughts are just
things and emotions are just things and
you know one of the kind of tools or
lessons that I've learned in sobriety is
you know addicts and alcoholics drink
because they don't want to feel they
want to change their emotional state
they don't want to feel however however
unconscious that decision is it's a
decision to try to not feel however they
feel right and and sobriety is about
understanding and learning and embracing
the fact that these emotions although
they may feel like they're going to kill
you
they're just emotions they have the
power that we attach to them and if we
can allow ourselves to just be okay
feeling them there is one thing that is
certain and that ultimately they will
shift and pass absolutely absolutely the
radical acceptance of our emotions even
the difficult ones is the cornerstone
but it's so scary it's scary it's scary
and and this is again when you parenting
we're helping your children very young
to start labeling their emotions not
trying to rush in and save your children
from difficult emotions because when you
save them from difficult emotions they
don't learn oh I was feeling sad fifteen
minutes ago and then emotion has now
passed mm-hm
so how do we step out we talk a little
bit more I mean we talked about it a
little bit yeah yes so there there are a
number of things that are so really this
idea of stepping out is about creating
the space so there's firstly and I
explore many different strategies in the
book but the first one is this instead
of I am feel you know I am said I'm
noticing that I'm said being labeling
your emotions what are what are two
other emotions that I might be feeling
writing very very powerful there's
incredibly valuable research showing
that through writing through putting
things into language you start
generating greater levels of insight and
this writing is not about ruminating or
dwelling it's about trying to understand
perspective taking
if fascinating when you working with
people and and I don't work physically
anymore I work often with individuals
who are running companies and you know
it's it's fascinating when someone is
stuck and they said to themselves
something like you know there's no way
I'll be able to shift my career or
there's no ways we're gonna have success
on this project or theirs so we stuck in
a story and I used to experience this
when I was working clinically as you
would say to someone you know what do we
need to do about the situation the
person would say I've got no idea
there's nothing I can do there's no hope
and then you might ask them a very like
simple question like you would say
something like if the wisest person in
the world was advising you what to do
what would they say and suddenly this
person who's now starting to physically
mentally look at things from a different
perspective now the wise person says oh
well they would tell me that I should do
this and listen listen listen listen
listen this so you already know the
answer it's it's it's fast it's
fascinating but but often when we are
stuck we stuck in our first-person
perspective and so when we start using
this perspective taking
what would the person who loves you most
in the world be advising we stop being
able to shift this in in therapy when I
was working as a therapist weird
we would often do this physically which
which sounds kind of bizarre but it's
it's very helpful as we would actually
sit two chairs next to each other and we
would ask the person to move physically
from one chair to the next having a
conversation with themselves so the
person who's stuck and the wise person
and it sounds you know but but what's
just incredible is it starts to create a
palpable shift um another thing that I
would say is you know often when we when
we stuck we talk to ourselves in the
first person so we'll say something like
I'm stuck I don't know what to do I
don't know what to do try shifting where
you say so Suzy what do you think you
should do right now about the situation
again it sounds kind of crazy but it
works it works we starting to create
space
mm-hm and in that space is something
incredibly powerful which is empowerment
and ownership of choice within that
there is the development of an
intellectual understanding a more
objective understanding of what the
problem is and and what the way forward
looks like but I feel like all too often
there's this massive gap in between the
intellectual understanding and the
tangible or sustainable behavioral
change yeah right it's sort of like I
know I need to do that and yet it still
doesn't happen or there's something
hamstringing that person that prevents
them from taking the action they have
enough awareness to know is what they
were supposed to be doing and yet they
just can't muster the the the will or
whatever you would deem it to get it
done yes yes what's going on and so
often what's going on there is is people
people even though they've got the
intellectual expertise around it are
still actually kind of in the
contemplation stage and it's it's it's
really you know the this is almost like
when you in a job in with your KPIs and
your bosses you've got to do these 10
things
today otherwise you're not going to get
a promotion or you know it feels
abstract and it feels like this is a
list of stuff that I've got to do but I
don't have any intrinsic investment in
it and so what is absolutely just
critical to on the ground behavior
change is moving from this intellect
into this is where these values come in
this is where these values come in like
what is what is the value to me
not okay I've got to lose weight in an
intellectual sense
but what is this being healthy mean to
me in being able to watch my children
grow up and I can give you you know I'll
give you an example of this as many
years ago I was working with a client
who's now a very good friend and he had
adopted a child from Nicaragua and so
this friend of mine had gone married
very late he hadn't been able to have
children and he adopted this kid and
this child had lived in the most
heartbreaking conditions in an orphanage
way for three years the child had been
fed through bars of a cribben untouched
and unhulled and my client for many many
many years had been trying to make
health changes he had gone to doctors
his wife was at him you know and he had
done it all and he hadn't been able to
shift and he very much had the story of
he travelled a lot I'm a consultant I
can't get into her tea and I I just
conjured and his child as the child grew
up had profound learning difficulties
that had likely been precipitated by
this experience in this orphanage but
the child turned out to be a remarkable
artist and one day this little boy draws
a picture and the picture is of this
individual in pain like excruciating
emotional pain
and the little boy not the age of 16
titles the picture the orphan and my
client says to the little boy or not to
the adolescent you know I understand
that you often draw experiences that you
had when you were in the orphanage but
why is it that you drawing a kind of 16
year old version of you but hauling at
the orphan and this little boy just
started sobbing and he said to his dad
because I know I will be orphaned again
you know I know that I will be orphaned
again and my client describes how and I
explore this in the book is his goal
that was a hefty goal I have to lose
weight which is this prison that he had
somehow wrapped himself around shifted
into a wanted to goal the wanted to goal
is the goal that's intrinsically felt
and values aligned and he was able to
and now long-standing Lee has made
successful changes to his health and
well-being so I think what's often
happens is we think that we can make
changes by exerting brute force against
ourselves you know we know we needed it
intellectually but we exert brute force
but sustainable change actually doesn't
happen in that way a sustainable change
happens when there's an intrinsically
felt motivation that is not a have to
but I want to a value that is important
to us it's a beautiful story it's
heartbreaking
yeah has a nice ending to it it's
powerful and I think you're I think
that's absolutely correct I think that
you know if somebody has a huge capacity
for self well and dedication and
devotion they could white-knuckle
themselves through the achievement of
some goal but ultimately it's not a
sustainable situation unless its value
values aligned and and you know that's
why I always kind of talk about
willingness and what a gift it is
because it's something you cannot you
can't give to somebody like if
somebody's willing or they're not like
it like somebody is willing to do
whatever it takes to get sober or
they're not right and how do you ignite
that in another individual and from what
I'm gathering from what
saying like I've always thought well
that's just theirs I'm powerless when it
comes to that if I'm trying to help
another human being but what you're
saying which is very interesting and I
haven't really I'm just thinking out
loud but if you can get them to direct
their attention towards their values and
then link up whatever that goal is or
that aspiration is in a way that aligns
with that values that's a starting point
to try to get them to a place where
perhaps some some willingness can begin
to flourish yes and and then there's the
habit you know then there's the cues in
the environment and they have a change
but I'll give you just a practical
research based example of this
imagine you are you know I keep going
back to chocolate cake because I'm
obviously okay but so okay so imagine
you've got a goal that you're trying to
lose weight I have to lose weight okay
and there's a piece of chocolate cake in
the refrigerator what we know is that
when you've got to have to goal so it's
not out of a sense of values but more
shame and obligation very often that
piece of chocolate cake we know in
research studies that what it does is it
actually ramps up temptation so have two
goals actually ramp up temptation they
make us want the thing that we can't
have and we focus and focus on that
there's resistance there's resistance so
now you take that and so you might say
well what about willpower you know what
about this what you were talking about
this white-knuckled willpower what about
willpower just brute force against it
but what's fascinating is your brain
processes taste sensation 195
milliseconds before you even know you
are making a choice hmm so what that
means is well you know self well how is
this anna sam harris
overrated idea your brain knows whether
you are gonna eat the chocolate cake
before you even know that you are making
a choice yeah that involves willpower so
your brains already decided you eating
the chocolate cake now you take that
same goal and you derive a sense of
wonder to motivation so intrinsically
values aligned this is this is what
why I don't want to eat the piece of
chocolate cake when you go through that
refrigerator instead of only seeing the
chocolate cake you see everything else
it revs down temptation and it actually
helps you to create sustainable behavior
change so this is critical and I think
so much of the so much of the
conversation about how do we change
habits is is superficial because what it
does is it's very much just about how do
you change your environment how do you
cue environment all that stuff is really
helpful but it is the intrinsic stuff
that allows it to be sustainable in a
real way right right right yeah I have
my own experience with this 11 years 11
years ago I was like 50 pounds
overweight and just junk food addict
couch potato type person and my wife of
course you know was like why don't you
try this why don't do this yours she's
like a spiritual seeker you know her by
her bed stand or all these amazing facts
about expanding your consciousness she's
always like it's her second nature to be
in this this sort of like
self-improvement Gestalt at all time and
I'm just like I'm more like I was
practicing lawyer at the time and I was
like that's cool for her like that's let
me do my thing no she was never vibing
me or anything like that she could just
see like a better version of me
beyond yeah it's like she's like you're
better like yeah you can be like I see
you you know you can't see yourself I
see you let me help you but no more she
extended her hand to help me yeah the
more I recoiled yeah even when it was
completely loving and not driving or
anything like that until she got to a
place where she's like she really had to
like decide like if this guy never
changes do I still want to be with it
yeah and she decided that she did and
she really not in a perfunctory
lip-service way like she let it go like
she just totally let it go yeah and she
actually apologized to me and said I'm
sorry like it's your life and I love you
and I'm loved being married to you and
like I release you to your experience
and there was something that I was not
conscious of at the time that was very
powerful because what it did was it
shifted my
awareness from to use your vernacular
from a should to a want because suddenly
I didn't have to do anything for her
yeah but it made the mirror suddenly
present itself in front of me and led me
to question what do I want for myself
which is a question I hadn't asked yet
because I was so focused on on you know
like what other people were expecting me
to do and and nothing was changing right
and so when I finally did ask that
question I was able to I was this was
all just in a very muddled intuitive way
I wish I had had this this is a book
that Julie would have given and she
would have said you should but that did
really kind of lead me into trying to
better define what my values were and
what I aspired for myself and that was
it a huge tremendous shift that
completely changed my life yeah I mean I
would not be having this conversation so
in the moment I guess what I'm getting
at is you know I'm I'm validating
everything that you're saying but also
wanting to make the point that sometimes
it's these tiny little subtle things
that can have a massive impact that we
shouldn't just give short shrift or skip
over like it can be those tiny gestures
that in the moment we may not feel are
significant and yet have profound him
like they are there I think one of the
biggest miss appreciations if it's such
a word is this idea that in order to
make change in our lives that it needs
to be you know let's sell up and go live
on a farm in Greece so let's and
actually there's just huge power in tiny
tweaks mmm in small shifts and there
might be shifts in the other shifts in
someone's seeing you you know this
beautiful soul born eyes I see you and I
still love you mm-hmm and that being
able to be experienced as someone who's
having the love regardless can free you
and being able to make tiny shifts in
our own lives can make a huge difference
yeah I love that phrase how do you say
it again so it's this beautiful it's a
talk about a mighty reaches this in
South Africa there's this absolutely
profoundly beautiful phrase which is
Subba Warner and anyone who's gone to
South Africa you hear a hundred times on
the streets it's all born and literally
translated means it's a greeting it's
hollow but literally translated means I
see you and by seeing you I bring you
into being mm-hmm just yeah it's not
beautiful yes how does this well let's
talk about the the these little these
little steps you this the tiny tweaks
because this is also like right in the
sweet spot of the things I like to talk
about and I talk about often you know
we're in this culture of life hacks and
shortcuts and like what's the least
amount of effort that I need to expend
in order to get this result that I want
and we kind of celebrate these people
that do extraordinary things and we
project onto them that this happened in
a condensed period of time or was
without failure and all of these things
and I think what gets lost in the
discussion around people that do
extraordinary things is that the path
towards that is contained fully and
completely in the tiny little things
that we do every single day anonymously
that in and of themselves seem
insignificant but which ultimately over
time move mountains yeah so and no one
likes to talk like just change that one
little thing yeah and so do that mean
not not to you know I'm by no means an
Elon Musk but but you know when I think
back to my own career you know this the
failings I mean I dropped out of
university and went backpacking around
the world for two years because I didn't
know what I wanted to do and then came
back and you know did my PhD and did my
postdoc but it was this idea of being
able to start shifting my understanding
of myself in terms of what I wanted but
even in my own you know day-to-day life
they ways that I managed my time that
are tiny
like one of the most important things
that I did even in trying to write this
book is I think there's this idea often
that like you know you you you I don't
know how you write but for me I
certainly you know get zero inspiration
when I'm on an aeroplane and jet-lagged
and so I realize that for me focus was
just incredibly important and so a tiny
tweak that I made just even in terms of
my own productivity was having one day a
week which is my appointment frictional
day where I do you know all of the other
stuff and then I've got deep work now
that's such a small shift that I made
which is literally just to shift to my
calendar but it was completely
completely changing in terms of my
productivity right and it's there's
nothing sexy about it it's one of the
most powerful changes that I've made
right like what are the tiny little
things that you can do that are small
shifts that you can then master and then
move on to the next thing yes right yes
the same at the same and I talked about
this in emotional jealousy that you know
if you in the wrong career or if you the
idea that you've got to give up your job
and completely change your life where as
if we start engaging with something that
would that we call job crafting this
idea that you might feel stuck in your
job and yes you may just give up your
job and move move on to something else
but actually what we can starting as we
can say you know what is what is this
again what is this emotionless feeling
of disengagement what value is
appointing to that's important for me it
might be about growth or it might be
about creativity that's missing and then
we can start saying well where can I
start finding more growth where can I
start finding more creativity where can
I start finding more collaboration and
so you know we can put our hands up for
different projects we can engage in
going to some meetings that we might not
have otherwise we can start crafting
things we can we can start networking in
different ways
so they're these small things that
ultimately create mm-hmm another
ecosystem for ya yeah everyone wants to
think that it's just about up and
quitting your job and now I'm gonna be a
stand-up comic or
but it begins with like well why don't
you just write a joke if you don't have
to quit your job yeah maybe you
shouldn't you probably shouldn't write
but how can you bring expression to that
repressed thing that is it is calling to
you in a way that doesn't need to
disrupt your life but ignites that spark
that will then lead you to whatever
comes next
yes yes which is which is just so
powerful and I think the other thing
that it does is it builds on the idea I
have a lot of people contact me saying
you know I'm an happy and my job what
should I do you know should I just give
it up but something hold you so most of
the time not all the time but something
might have called that person to that
particular job and they might have
developed particular expertise that is
valuable and it becomes a stepping stone
to there are other might inform it might
benefit them and the other thing but I
think it goes back to emotional agility
because let's say you're in your job and
to use the example of the stand-up comic
you're repressing that impulse because
you have this story that that's not the
purview of the responsible breadwinner
right and so you're pushing it aside
you're exerting all this energy to deny
it you know it's there but you're trying
your best to not consciously engage it
yeah emotional agility would be oh
that's kind of that's tapping on me
yeah let's like maybe let's explore that
like okay I'll write a joke you know let
me but I can do it in a way that's
somewhat dispassionate and I don't have
to be you get all crazy about it but
like hmm okay yes notice yes yeah yeah
it's beautiful and then on top of that
to kind of piggyback onto that there's
this idea that you talk about which is
the teeter-tottering
right yes you want to talk about that I
do yeah I love this too and I have ideas
about this but explain what that means
so it's this idea so so you know again
in the book what I do is I talk about
these four movements I talk about
showing up which is and noticing your
thoughts and your emotions in
compassionate ways stepping out which is
creating the space walking your wire
which is this how do we make values
align choices and then moving on via
this is this tiny
weeks as well as this teeter-totter
principle so and the the idea behind
this is that often when in life whether
it's in relationships or at work we
develop strong levels of over competence
so the idea here is that you can do your
job with your eyes closed or you know
what to expect and this doesn't mean you
aren't busy you might be very busy doing
something in a roadway and when we over
competent it's a very strong risk factor
for just feelings of disengagement and
and ultimate ultimately a sense of
disempowerment so over competence is
very difficult for us but by the same
token human beings like a comfort and we
really struggle with the opposite which
is over challenge of a challenge in a
job is where you keep feeling like
you're being thrown in the deep end you
never know what's going on the goals
keep on changing it's again a very
strong risk factor for disengagement and
so the the sweet spot of growth in our
lives is where we neither over competent
nor over challenged so what are we doing
is we are working at the edge of our
ability so keeping on again pushing the
boundary not just for the sake of it
again in a values of and where you can
take that same idea and you can apply it
in relationships where you in a
relationship where you you know go out
with your spouse you go to a movie you
know what the person's opinion is of the
movie you know what they can order it
don't know you know what you're going to
talk about it dinner you over competence
in that relationship and it's a risk
factor for that relationship you also
don't want to be over challenged where
you're walking on eggshells so what do
we do when we are trying to work at the
edge of our ability usually what we're
trying to do is we're trying to either
expand breadth or depth breadth might be
we trying new things we moving into
environments that are maybe new we maybe
instead of going out with the same group
of friends with our spouse every week or
the same movie we're trying different
things so that's breadth depth is where
you start going deeper where
you start developing greater levels of
expertise or with your spouse you start
having conversations that you might not
have had for the past 20 years you know
when you actually ask the person what
their dreams were or what their fears
were or so depth and breadth are usually
where's that we start expanding the the
edge and moving at the edge of our
ability and it's in that zone that we
have our greatest levels of growth and
yes discomfort but discomfort is again
the price of admission to a meaningful
life right and and I think in the in the
book you use the example of the gymnast
on the walking on the beam right and and
as that person loses their balance it's
their core strength
aka their emotional agility that allows
them to then stabilize themselves once
again yeah it's sort of like I had a
couple weeks ago I had the climber Alex
Honnold
in here yeah who's just just brilliant
what he does and it's it's so
extraordinary what he's able to do and I
think it really is a testament in many
ways to this principle because he
doesn't just up and climb El Cap without
ropes you know out of the blue he's been
doing this his whole life and you know
it's just okay one wall a little bit
more challenging than the last one in
the same way you know Laird Hamilton can
surf this gigantic wave it doesn't
happen overnight he doesn't go from a
six foot wave to a 20 foot wave he goes
from a six foot wave to a six and a half
wave right taking these incremental
little steps to push that envelope of
comfort or discomfort just the tiniest
amount until there's an acclamation and
then you're ready for the next challenge
yeah and it's it's a dishonor to our
human imperfections to sell the
narrative that it's simply something
that happens in one fell swoop that you
know just happens right and that is the
narrative that's what we read we read it
in that and we love that hero's story
and he believed that that's how it
occurred but yeah because we wanna we
want we want these people to be bigger
than life yeah but they're all humans
just like we are no yeah it's hard
though how does this work do you
have you had any experience working with
people in the throes of some form of
addiction because that throws in an
additional variable into this equation
because if somebody is if it's a
substance addiction then they're being
compelled physiologically in a way that
kind of makes it a little more tricky
yeah the average person who's just stuck
in a thought pattern but I think looking
at addiction from a broader perspective
and as a spectrum I think on some level
we're all addicts we're we all engage in
compulsive behaviors to some form or
another in ways that lead us astray so
is there a is there a tweak on this or
you have any sense of I mean would it be
the same application if you were like
treating somebody who's dealing with so
a lot of these ideas have been applied
in you know across many clinical
contexts and pain addiction depression
anxiety and you know they they are
powerful I mean I think that the thing
with addiction that you alluded to
earlier is that addiction is very often
a emotion regulation strategy you know
what's happened not in the addiction as
it ultimately presents but what's
happened very early on is that it is a
way of regulating our emotions and so
you know we stopped being able to pass
out short-term strategies that are
effective and ineffective and long-term
strategies that are ineffective and
ineffective and short-term strategies
that people use to regulate their
emotions that are effective of course
are things like exercise or going to
jail or getting enough sleep and the
ineffective ones or the overeating or
drink you know drinking and all of those
kind of things the long-term effect of
is when we are starting to face into the
situation in a way that is active that's
actually starting to move us into action
and that is direct it that's recognizing
the situation for what it is and so so
these ideas are absolutely applicable
across all contexts but I think with the
you know additional layer of recognition
addiction has often started early on mmm
as a maybe not even thought out but but
avoidance strategy of pain yeah of
course you know of course yeah there's
some discomfort that you're I mean the
the adage goes you know the the drugs
and the alcohol that's not the addiction
that's the solution right the the
addiction is rooted in the emotional
pain that is often can be traced back
you know are you familiar with gab or Ma
Tei and the work that he's done with
early emotional trauma yeah and all of
that so that's that and then and then
once you get sober the the delusion is
that you solve the problem but actually
you've just taken away your medication
you know then you have to like treat the
underlying condition which is that sense
of disease that emotional that emotional
pain and that involves confronting it in
a way that I think you know these tools
are highly applicable yeah yeah change
and the act of learning a new coping
straight like new different adaptive
coping strategies right right right
right how do you see this playing out we
talked about the micro and the macro
most of what we've been talking about is
is the micro but like what's a good
example of how emotional rigidity is
creating social societal problems that
we need to look at do you have an
example for that well well it's it's I
mean it's our tide is obviously yeah
yeah I mean I think that there I think
that there many examples there many
examples where our difficulty in even
seeing our own pain and being able to
recognize our own sadness or anger cuts
us off for cuts us off from being able
to be empathetic and compassionate to
the other right and and and and intimate
to the extent that you're you're capable
of with the people that you care about
yeah yeah so I think something it plays
hard I mean I think it plays out into
the way we treat the earth I think it
plays out into the dehumanizing of the
other because when we when we cutting
ourselves off from our own you know and
we're talking at the extreme here but if
we're cutting ourselves off from our own
difficult emotion or even experiencing
this narrative where we saying things
like well you know it's it's all just
about being positive what that starts to
imply is that people who are in pain
people who are in poverty people who are
in discrimination should you know just
choose a better attitude basically you
know there's there's this very very you
know it is the abrogation of societal
responsibility because there's there's
there's this idea that's baked into a
narrative that's a narrative that says
that only positive emotions are the ones
that matter and that you should simply
just choose your positive emotions
rather than be open and compassionate to
the fragmented reality of human
experience that the flip side of that is
what a then starts to imply is that when
people are in and obviously again this
is the extreme that when people are in
difficulty it's because they've got a
bad attitude because they haven't been
able to move themselves into this
positive space right and the irony of
course is that if you can embrace all of
that emotional complexity you could
potentially get to a place where you
have a positive attitude I'm not anti
happiness I actually think that what I'm
talking about is the pathway to
authentic happiness mmm-hmm
it's it's it's well happiness is a
tricky word you know a life of purpose
and fulfillment a life of personal
meaning to you yeah but but even if we
think about if we think about hate in a
political spectrum you know there is
there is this idea that there is the
other that there's there's this good and
this bad
the right and the wrong days and
sometimes we just we you know if the
gods of right came down and said to you
you know you're right that person is a
complete idiot you still get to choose
how you want to engage with them and
unfortunately I think what happens is in
our being hooked and being emotionally
rigid about being right we've lost our
ability to have the conversation that
really matters mm-hmm-hmm yeah and I
think in that example that you just gave
you know to let's say you somebody wrong
to you and you have justifiable anger or
you hold a resentment towards that
person ultimately you're the one who's
suffering as a result of that right yes
yes it's not serving you that way no
matter how correct that you are I'm
often I'm often interviewed by Harvard
Business Review and you know it's and
people will often ask questions like
what if my bosses are complete idiots
like what if my boss really is a
complete idiot or what if this
organization has really done me wrong or
what if my team member really is a
slacker and it just reaches the point
and and with complete compassion you can
kind of understand that frustration but
if the gods of right came down and said
you were right like you are right you
are being mistreated you are right was
that we you know where does that leave
you you know is your action workable or
is it not workable is your action
bringing you closer to being the person
you want to be you know if you are
feeling wronged by your co-worker and so
you disengaging shutting down in your
career not contributing how is that
serving your career goals you know and
it might be that yes this is a case
where you want to make a shift where you
want to make a tweak but but I think you
know one form of rigidity of emotional
rigidity is being hooked on being right
mhm yeah that's a big one I think yeah
right rather than rather than asking the
question of is my reaction serving right
what I'm trying to write B and in
sobriety they said you want to be right
or do you want to be happy yeah right
yeah and so and happy would be
recontextualize in your example as you
know do you want it do you want to be
right or do you want to live a life in
accordance with your values correct
right yeah yeah
all right well we gotta wrap this up
here but but let's just leave the
listeners with you know some sense of a
first perhaps somebody who's listening
the lights are going on for the first
time and they're like oh my god I've
been telling myself this of course you
know pick up the Polka motional agility
and this will see or see yourself
through and hopefully raise additional
awareness around these things but what
is like a first step for somebody who's
on the very first page of beginning this
process of trying to better understand
their motivations and what their values
are absolutely so just to some emotional
agility is the ability to be with your
thoughts your emotions your stories in
ways that are compassionate curious and
courageous and to take actions that are
concordant with your values and so I
think a first step is if you're someone
who becomes judgy about whether you
right or wrong whether you should or
shouldn't have a story one of the most
critical aspects is ending the struggle
by dropping the rope and what I mean by
that is just making a conscious choice
to notice your emotions it's a great
first place to start well thank you very
much thank you so glad it worked out
yeah it's great the book is amazing
Congrats on all your success it's super
well deserved
I mean what's what's next for you I feel
like you feel this pressure now you got
a couple of things that I want to do if
anyone this so I want to firstly I want
to write a children's book because I
just think it would be a beautiful fun
project around some of these ideas I was
interviewed by the New York Times on
these ideas as they're relate to
children and I want to write a book for
kids so if Jamie Lee Curtis is listening
and you were number one I think I just
love her
I love work so that's so that's
something that I want to do one of the
other things that I'm working on is
taking these ideas and when often people
struggle with how do I actually in act
like you actually do well what I'm
working on at the moment is designing a
[Music]
computer program so it's it's a kind of
system based application where people
can input some of the issues that they
struggling with and will answer some
questions about that and what it starts
to do is to actually use that
information to coach them through that's
a solo in an app format yeah so it's a
combination of a kind of survey where
people are completing information but
it's but it's actually providing
evidence-based coaching feedback to them
so that's that's what I'm starting to
work on yeah and you're you're on the
road speaking all the time right I did a
lot of speaking and you know I don't
work with Harvard Medical School and so
I've um yeah but but those that those
are things that I'm starting to explore
now awesome and if people want to
connect with you they're inspired by
your message where is the best please do
I love hearing from people so I'm on all
social media I think then get sort of
gets out of hand as to what social media
but also on my website the quiz is at
Susan David come forward slash learn and
if anyone wants to connect there's
there's information on my website as
well all right thanks so much thank you